i'm always fascinated about the making
of a movie and what really goes on
behind the scenes
so what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of like
f9
i mean i can say speak for myself and
saying that that space scene we did was
very difficult uh to do um in terms of
us having uh layers of clothes on
harnesses
being suspended in air having to you
know
you know feel like we were in space for
real it was very uncomfortable
very hot were you trying to say that
making movies is not
luxurious if you have a lot of
great stunts i would say it's not as
luxurious as people think it is i mean
you see how tom cruise people get broken
bones they get hurt
um there's all type of things that can
happen but it's all for the fans and
it's all for the people that watch
how does it feel to actually beat tom
cruise at something because you guys
went to space
before he could absolutely went to space
before he could
it feels great by the way to up one
on tom cruise at any moment in life you
know at any time
and richard branson and elon musk so i
feel good about that
yeah i actually obviously i want to talk
about you and the movie but i got to
give credit to cruz because
um he what he does in those mission
impossible movies what he's really doing
is jaw-dropping you know i agree man i'm
a fan of that franchise as well
believe it what i i definitely want to
know um
what was it like for you when justin
actually pulled you aside and said by
the way yeah we're going to go to space
when justin pulled me inside and said
we're going to space i was ecstatic
i was loving it i was like i didn't
think that there was anything we haven't
done and now they just came up with it
perfect yeah that's the thing that i was
because i was wondering like
what is it going to be when is fast
going to get like into the deep
ocean or into outer space i'm like
there's only so many places you guys can
go
man listen i felt the same way we had
the submarine in one of the
one of the movies but i feel like we
need to do underwater fighting or we
need to do like
uh in air fighting somehow but outer
space
out of this world i would have never
imagined it at this early in the game
has justin told you anything about the
next one
nope they keep stuff like that pretty
much a secret because they don't want to
give away stuff even to the cast members
believe that
if vin diesel was a car what kind of car
would he be
if in diesel was a car whatever the most
sturdy um
resilient powerful car that there is
he'd probably be a hummer of some sort
some sort of military-grade car i would
say
uh when you're actually making a film
like this
what how long is the shoot for you and
like what is it like behind the scenes
with everyone
i'm sorry behind the scenes it's more
love than what you see on camera
so it's amazing shooting and we have a
great time i mean i couldn't
i don't know how better to speak on the
chemistry
off and on camera but it's great that's
what makes it great the memories that we
have
just to share for all of the times we've
been together
on that note congrats on the movie uh i
hope it's a huge hit for you guys
thank you bro cool thank you for your
time